let's say that Y is equal to 6 over x
squared what I want to do in this video
is figure out what is what is the second
derivative of Y with respect to X and if
you're wondering where this notation
comes from for a second derivative
imagine if you started with your Y and
you first take a derivative and we've
seen this notation before so that would
be the first derivative then we want to
take the derivative of that
so we then want to take the derivative
of that to get us our second derivative
and so that's where that notation looks
comes from it looks like we're having
you have a d squared D times D although
you're not really multiplying them
applying the derivative operator twice
it looks like you have a DX squared
once again you're not multiplying them
you're just applying the operator twice
but that's where that notation actually
comes from well let's first take the
first derivative of Y with respect to X
and to do that let's just remind
ourselves that we just have two that we
just have to apply the power rule here
and we can just remind ourselves based
on the fact that Y is equal to 6 X to
the negative 2 so let's take the
derivative of both sides of this with
respect to X so with respect to X I'm
going to do that and so on the left hand
side I'm going to have dy/dx is equal to
now on the right hand side take our
negative 2 multiply it times the 6 it's
going to get negative 12 X to the
negative 2 minus 1 is X to the negative
3 and actually let me give myself a
little bit more space here so this is
negative 12 X to the negative 3 and now
let's take the derivative of that with
respect to X so I'm going to apply the
derivative operator again so the
derivative with respect to X now the
left hand side gets the second
derivative of Y with respect to X is
going to be equal to well we just have
used the power rule again negative 3
times negative 12 is positive 36
x times x to the well negative 3 minus 1
is negative 4 power which we could also
write as 36 over X to the fourth power
and we're done